avec seulement une valise et parfois
leur animal de compagnie ces ukrainiens
prennent le chemin de l'exil
comme ces familles qui patientent dans
ce hall de gare du sud est de la pologne
ils sont trois millions à avoir fui le
pays depuis le début de l'invasion russe
cet exode rapide et massif et sans
précédent ten times of this place mais
aussi bien pour les migrations internes
que les déplacements de réfugiés
c'est l'un des mouvements les plus
importants que nous ayons vues sur le
continent européen et certainement même
dans le monde entier comme nous l'avons
vu les destructions ont été très
importants
les besoins humanitaires aussi sont très
si les web les hommes considéré en âge
de se battre ne sont pas autorisés à
quitter l'ukraine la moitié de ces
réfugiés sont donc des enfants une
population particulièrement vulnérable
un risque très important c'est le risque
d'exploitation les risques de traite des
êtres humains exploitation sous toutes
ses formes c'est à dire exploitation
sexuelle contrainte à commettre des
délits
travail forcé
obligations à mendier ce sont vraiment
des risques d'exploitation sous toutes
leurs formes c'est aussi le risque pour
les enfants de disparaître 60% des
réfugiés ukrainiens sont actuellement en
pologne mais pour certains ce n'est
qu'une étape des centres d'accueil sont
ouverts plus à l'ouest de l'europe comme
à berlin où ici à paris depuis trois
semaines 18000 personnes fuyant la
guerre en ukraine sont arrivés en france